hey everybody welcome to lab coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today I have a
really exciting pool request that we're
gonna review and hopefully merge so I
just started looking at it but I'm
excited there's a lot of awesome things
that are done in this pool request but I
think I'm probably most excited about
the use of react hooks so if you don't
know what hooks are hopefully you'll
know a little bit more about them by the
end of this stream this is gonna be kind
of a short stream I just want to try to
get through this pull request and merge
it test it out and and then we'll
probably finish up with some question
and answer got started a little bit
later this morning so let's let's get
right into it so the first thing we're
gonna do is read a little bit about pull
requests like I mean I'm not gonna read
it out loud but we're just gonna kind of
review
shout out to Chris Brown e55 for this
amazing pool request so let's just do a
quick overview we'll check out what's
changing the files and then we'll pull
it down as a separate branch test it out
locally a little bit okay so some of
some of the changes here like I said I
just started to look at this so this is
all gonna be fresh we're gonna be
looking at this together so he put in a
use reducer so we're not going to
clutter the component with a lot of
states so that's that's cool
logic is now in the reducer and it's in
a separate file okay we got some stuff
in here to avoid rear-ending which is
good as performance enhancing right
we did not face oh cool so we got rid of
that switch statement I mean I love
switch statements but they they are
quite long sometimes so that's cool I'm
excited to see what that looks like
another replaced switch statement very
cool random number generator okay cool
so we could set a minimum maximum number
awesome okay cool so alright so hooks
has changed some stuff in dev tools and
Chris is recommending that we switch to
this experimental version of dev tools
that does look really cool so I'll
probably do that I don't know if I'll
get to that in this stream but thank you
for the for the advice there also a
prettier config I love this so I usually
do something like this in all my
projects and I have Auto formatting I
hadn't gotten around to setting it up so
I'm super excited about this at some
point we'll probably set up like husky
to do some automated formatting on
commit but this is this is really
awesome so thank you for that all right
now let's check out the files in case
you don't know how I got to this point I
just went to the battle math for
positive where and github the links in
the description and I I just clicked on
pull requests and then this was the the
first pull request in there right so we
also have an issue that I think I made
that issue I think it was just a readme
or something so now first thing you see
is this now I'm going to go to the
actual files changed so we can see the
changes actually let me switch it to
split
okay so I like viewing it like a split
so on the left-hand side it'll show you
your files now as they are and on the
right-hand side it will show you what
the files will be like if you merge this
pull request right so there was no
prettier config before that's why
there's nothing here so now we have this
it has right
no semicolons use single quotes it tab
with two which is awesome that's that's
how I roll
we have all significant reduction in the
amount of code here look at that I love
that so all the read is stuff that's
going away so it's been deleted in green
and stuff that's been added so look at
that so so much it's going to be gone
out of that app touch a s file it's
gonna be much easier to figure out
what's going on like it's terms of like
layout so now we do have use reducer use
call back use effect these are those
hooks right or I mean this is not all
the hooks but like this is coming from
the react hooks which we'll talk about
more all right and we also have this a
producer component now and we're pulling
in state a reducer and types from there
so that's awesome let's let's scroll
down I love that okay okay so we have
some additions now too right so let's go
through this and try to figure out
what's going on it's always good to try
to figure out what's going on before you
attempt to merge a pull request right
you never want to merge a pull request
that that you don't understand number
one like it somebody could be trying to
mess with you mess up your project which
I've never ever had happened but it's
possible
number two you still have to be
responsible for maintaining your own
project and if you don't understand how
your project works then
how are you gonna maintain it right so
Oh also notice I did move the the view
of my face up so we had some people say
that it was being blocked by a watermark
freaka can't watermark so hopefully
that's better let me know what you think
about that is it does this work for you
is it blocking too much let me know so
alright so inside of our our app they
have we move to a functional component
here I believe we have okay so number
one we move to a functional component
which is awesome I keep saying like
number one number two and stuff I don't
know I don't know what's wrong with me
today it's just talking and list so use
reduce okay so we're pulling out
answered a number of enemies so this is
all our state right so we're making our
state available from our reducer all
right so this is what Chris was talking
about when we're preventing rendering
right so that's awesome these are very
helpful comments thank you Chris
so memoization if you're not familiar
with memoization basically it's alright
think of it almost like caching for like
a function right hopefully that makes
sense right so it's not not memorization
which it kind of sounds like but
memoization so you know basically
save us in this case it saves us from
rendering something if the result is
going to be exactly the same anyway
right why are you render it let's see
handle mode picker he's called back just
finish well and notice like all these
are not right we need to set which we
need to do all of our state changes and
everything in our reducer file right so
now we're not directly doing like set
state or anything like that we're all
using this this dispatch right so we're
gonna look at the next file that we'll
see is that dispatch file so hopefully
this will make more sense but right when
we handle answer change its going to
dispatch basically everything we're
doing now is going to dispatch consume
it was submit we now have a theme
actually we had that before I put that
in last time didn't I okay sorry I
forgot about that okay this is cool so
this is the equivalent of component did
mount for a functional component so it's
use effect awesome that's gonna give us
a new a new problem on on component the
component loading component did mount
right okay so this should probably be
pretty much the same I do I think Chris
added a key so I think I remember a
mention of that so that's awesome you do
get a warning in the console if there's
no key on like iterated elements and all
right cool now here is the new stuff
like a lot of the most of the new stuff
this a producer j/s file so every time
we see this export that means like we we
can basically have access to that so you
see it matches up with that random
number generator that we had access to
an app djf we have access to the types
a reducer right so anytime you see that
like we can basically use that in other
files and import it alright so now we
have this random number generator that
allows us to have a min Animax which is
awesome so this will come in handy too
like if we want to add modes where you
could do double digit numbers then we
want to set the minimum to a double
digit number right so that's that's
pretty sweet
all right so now we have our types which
see these look like they're all are kind
of actions right for function here's our
reducer right so we do have our types
this this is actually a very reminiscent
of like Redux style so if you've done
Redux this this is very similar alright
so if we want to set an answer right
then we're returning the state so this
is this means when you see this dot dot
dot state that means we're gonna take
the current state as it is and merge it
with this so the rest of the state will
remain unchanged except for answer right
and then our action payload which is
whatever we've passed it into passed
into that meaning the the answer that's
been typed in is gonna come in here so
that's cool and it's the same way for
for like at an enemy so you can see
still some familiar right like we're
we're not gonna add any more than six
enemies right but see this is basically
just changing your state right alright
so let's get down because some of these
are pretty much the same I'm gonna check
the answer
okay so we're using eval here which
normally you don't want to use eval but
Chris is explaining that eval is safe
because we control the input okay so
that's that's cool
let's see yes
cool this is really cool update from
so I'm just looking at this I'll point
out some stuff that's like really
different you can see here we're still
just taking our our actions and just
basically updating state all right like
we were before all right but now this
has all been abstracted out right and
now it's it's in our reduced a producer
component the same way set mode invalid
actions
cool and now we have an error so this is
a big switch statement right and the
default case for the switch is what
happens when something is a value is
passed that doesn't need any of the
other cases right so now we have an
error invalid action which that's pretty
cool okay and then here's our initial
state which looks just like our state
did look right I use our operators so
that is really awesome so next step is
let's pull this down verify that
everything works and then maybe we'll
merge it so let's see I want to make
sure I stay on top of the chat here so
let me now that we've kind of gone
through the step one I'm going to go to
the chat just for a minute here and
answer a few questions and then we'll
we'll pull this down and test it out
rabbit works javascript says our hooks
available in react native as a
production feature I didn't think they
were mature enough yet yes so as of
react native version 0.50 9.0 hooks are
available in react native so the current
latest version as of yesterday was 0.5
9.1 so if you update react native to the
latest version you can use hooks that's
a good question
it did take a little a little while for
hooks to come out for react native after
they come out for regular react but I
think it wasn't too long to wait
I just kept checking like I was watching
the thread the github
I guess issue that was talking about it
so I knew exactly when they were coming
out I was pretty excited about it all
right
Gaming with us underscore whitey says I
am just eleven years old and learned
complete HTML PHP in sequel that's
awesome
keep up the good work you're gonna be by
the time you get to be my age you're
gonna be a genius in web development see
I'm skipping over some stuff there are
some good comments in there and of
course anybody watching can read read
along with the chat but I'm just looking
for questions right now just to kind of
keep things going quickly
with language okay what language do you
think is better for service a PHP or go
I've used PHP before I've never used go
to be honest with you if you can ask me
what my favorite server-side languages
I'm gonna say no to so JavaScript but
but that's because I'm I'm most
comfortable coding with that right so
that's not that's a very like that
response is very much based on my
experience and not anything objective
see
all right cool I think I got through the
the questions if I missed your question
like go ahead and repost it and I'll try
to get to it on the next round through
let's let me make note of where I left
off at 8 48 48 okay let's go back to
this and I'm gonna double check the
syntax it's been a little while since
I've actually had to pull down a pool
request from github so let me think
locally you see that comes up checking
out full requests locally see if this
this is what I want
area git fetch origin fool idea okay the
IDS - okay
so let's do git fetch origin pull how I
did forget the rest of it give fetch
origin pool okay there's slash slash ID
slash add branch name / ID /
oops not / - oops head and we can name
the branch whatever we wanted to it
doesn't have to be the name of the
branch currently for that pool request
so I'm just going to name this one Chris
hooks yeah since Chris submitted the
pool request and the most exciting thing
to me out of here is the hook so let's
see yeah
alright awesome now we can do a git
checkout and we have the Chris hooks
branch
let's do yarn just to make sure
okay so sorry that was hard to see right
so always do yarn just to make sure you
have all the packages ready
it stinks if you forget to do that and
your tests and stuff out and there are
errors and things don't work and then
you realize you forgot to pull in any
new packages so in this case there
weren't any new packages but it's just a
good habit to get into so you can see we
have our new files where's uh let's see
there we go there's an app producer
all right so let's actually get to the
to the testing here's our app right and
we have addition subtraction
multiplication division alright let's do
some of these we do one will get it
right I still never put in the being
able to use the Enter key so I
definitely need to do that but
forgetting that
let's see cool let's just try try this
one so what is that 27 I think so yay
cool all right which one of these do you
think looks the best and go leave it on
that everyone looks the best I'm not
sure I'll leave it on this pink for now
I that's its problem maybe like the
least jarring on the ice right now okay
so that looks good it looks like
everything works I mean I could probably
get out the console and see we had no
errors the whole time which is awesome
yeah so what do y'all think are there
any objections to merging this pool
request if anybody has any objections
let me know now within the next minute
or so otherwise let's let's merge this
pull request so I'm gonna give y'all
just like ice it's probably just a
minute or less to to let me know if
there's anything in this pool request
that you think absolutely should not be
merged we do have a question of why is
it called hooks I think it's like
there's there's precedent set already
like in other frameworks for having
these like hooks into life cycle methods
and stuff so
I think that's why why they went with
hooks right so it's a familiar term for
what they're doing
so I know it's not like react came up
with the name hooks out of nowhere right
there are hooks and like I used to do
WordPress dev back in the day and so
like there are hooks in WordPress right
so that they it's like a familiar design
pattern I guess you call it
Nikki says that Visual Studio code
github pull request extension is great
for this oh okay cool yeah I've never
I've never used any of the like get
extension stuff before maybe I'll have
to try that out
creepy says his atom code editor good
enough for the web for what yeah yeah I
like atom all right so it looks like
there are no objections to merging this
full request so let's merge it so first
thing I'm going to do is go get merge
master so this is going to merge
anything from master into put into this
one now I already know that there's
nothing that I've updated a master but I
like to do this to first see like have I
updated anything for in masters since
this pull request was submitted so i
merge it there that way if there are any
merge conflicts or anything if it really
messes stuff up I'm messing up the the
branch and not master all right
otherwise if I were to do it the other
way around and try to first merge this
branch into master I could potentially
mess up my master branch and if I were
to need to make a change like an
emergency change and push that out
really quick that could be bad right so
this in my mind is much safer here let
me make this bigger we can actually see
what's going on okay so everything's up
to date like just like I assumed it
would be alright now let's do a git
checkout master and we'll do get merge
and merge the hooks yay okay and it's
I'm just always in a habit of doing that
yarn you know after we do anything like
that just to be sure okay so now
everything's merged in that was an easy
merge sometimes you have merged
conflicts and when that happened
you'll actually have to go into the
files that have let's say that the same
line of code was edited you know at this
at the same time right like somebody
made the pool request they edited their
line and then afterwards I did something
on master where I edited the same line
and then I tried to merge we'd have to
decide whose edits are going to stay so
you would manually go in there and
either get rid of completely of one of
the edits or the other or have a
combination of the two
all right so thankfully we didn't have
to do that if you stay on top of your
pull request and get them in there like
as they come in you can decrease the
chance of having to do having to deal
with merge conflicts also if you make
sure that you recommend that when people
do a pull request they only change like
very small things that can help as well
definitely I don't think we have a
contributing MD file yet no but you know
you can explain it in there to like
remind people you know hey make sure you
have everything up to date like
frequently merge in what's going on in
master into your PR I even like to say
like hey before you submit a pull
request do one last merge from master to
make sure your stuffs up to date and
then the person doing the pull request
handles any merge conflicts and then and
that can greatly increase your chances
of getting your pull request merge not
just in this project but in any other
project so it's kind of like the polite
way to do a pull request but all right
so that's that's cool and we'll just
just to prove like everything still
works all right here we go it works and
let's just put in
right so that should give us let's just
like verify right we're not getting any
more than six right hey that's right one
okay so it still works
and now cool so I have a few minutes
left before I have to start doing work
stuff let me double check my calendar
really quick to just see exactly when my
first meeting is okay all right we're
good so let me go back to the live chat
and answer some you know any of the
remaining questions also let me push
this I forgot to push this up to get up
so let's do get push okay so now we
pushed that lets check out our repo so I
forgot about this so look it's already
changed to say merged so I don't have to
come back in here and do anything you
know github detects that I've merged
this these changes in and it
automatically says it's merged if we go
to pull requests now there's no more
open ones there's a close one and if we
go back to our code
let's check contributors this should be
yep so now there are two contributors
right and Chris is actually the number
one contributor on this this repository
right now so congratulations on that and
this is going by commits right so yeah
so if anybody wants to get on this
contributors board submit a pull request
okay so that's it for the code portion
now let me finish up with the questions
and they don't have to get to work
sorry I'm trying to find my place
alright creepy says how much can i
really make as a web developer because I
really love web developing and I want to
be a front-end developer ok that's a
hard question to answer because it
depends on where you're where you live
like what part of the world or even what
part of the country you live in
and there's a huge range of salary right
which is going to depend a lot upon like
your years of experience you know your
company and stuff so I've seen jobs you
know people offering even in the United
States offering as low as like like
fifty thousand dollars for a front-end
developer right and then I've seen jobs
offering over a hundred thousand dollars
for a developer for front-end developer
it's somewhat rare to be over a hundred
thousand dollars unless you're in a
bigger city if you kind of switch over
to full stack or become a software
engineer those salaries can get higher
than that but it's it's quite a large
range salary range in the United States
all creepy says in India yeah honestly I
have no idea what the salary ranges in
India but I know we have a lot of
viewers from India so if anybody has any
insight into that please let creepy know
in the in the live chat nikki says how
do you handle merge conflicts in your
log file i delete both and do a fresh
install actually that's a great idea to
just do fresh install and delete i i
never directly edit the lock file and i
recommend never delete directly editing
your luck file if you don't know what
we're talking about it's this yarn lock
right here
so like this this thing is just kind of
like pretty crazy right this is you're
not meant to directly edit this this is
created by yarn based on your
package.json and it keeps you know track
of all the the packages that are
installed all the node modules and all
the individual versions so yeah if there
happens to be
conflict I I think Nikki's advice is is
perfect just delete do a freshen so
see
creepy says but what I need a CS degree
to be a web developer and can I get
higher chances in the future in the
United States you definitely don't need
a computer science degree I don't know
what it's like in India though so I
don't want to give you advice there
because I don't really have knowledge of
that
troll master says web developer doesn't
even need a brain these days that is
like so perfect for the name troll
master so you're staying on brand there
HD movies Pakistan says dear sir please
send your email you can reach out my
email is out there I have a lot of
contact info in the description of this
video so you know reach out to me on
social media and stuff like my contact
info for like every part of my life is
out there and freely available online so
it's not hard to get trolled master
system so a web developer is not a
software engineer alright here's when it
comes to titles like web developers
software engineer front-end back-end
they are so mixed up these days like
from company to company it's it's
different those will be defined
differently right so you could be
labeled a front-end developer at one job
doing the same thing as a software
engineers going at a different job or a
full-stack engineers doing a different
job it's it's really so like there are
companies that just don't understand the
differences so don't don't take titles
like that seriously like let's say if
you don't think you're a full-stack if
you think you're just mostly front-end
don't be afraid to apply to a full stack
job because or a software engineering
job because the titles really don't mean
that much in terms of what you'll be
doing at your job at least that's been
been my experience I applied for a lot
of different jobs a few months ago and
got a lot of interviews and it was like
every job had a different title but they
pretty much all were doing exactly the
same thing music places how to become
the best coder without a degree I would
say code a little bit every day keep
trying to code like actual websites and
learn you know that's the best thing
right like people with a computer
science degree don't necessarily code
like real things every day right so if
you code somebody goes to school for
four years for computers
I agree but you code every day for four
years like real projects you both come
out you're gonna have a really good
portfolio and you're gonna have a lot of
real-world experience you probably will
be a better coder at that point giving
up everything else being equal right
like let's say you both have the same IQ
and all that you know right so there's
actually coding is the best way to
become better at coding practice just
keep practicing
and that's what creepy said practice in
online courses yeah for sure
Jacob Evan says I don't have a computer
science degree and I work as a react
developer at discover C that's awesome
yeah like I do not have a computer
science degree now I I have a business
degree so I have a college degree but I
don't have a cute puter science degree
and I'm a senior software engineer for
Dick's Sporting Goods so I do react
development for react native development
for them right now
user clay says how to become a developer
and how to earn money online well I
think that goes along with your earlier
question like just take online courses
and practice HD movies Pakistan says
okay sir Thanks yes so let me know if
you if you really need to get a hold of
me for something you know just send me a
message on probably Twitter it would be
the best way yeah that would probably
the best
and see let's see
trol master I just deleted that message
it wasn't like too bad but I want to
keep this safe for children so that's
just to let you know why I deleted that
one all right a man Amanda
jello I'm sorry I probably messed up the
pronunciation your name cuz I'm trying
to learn advanced react and redux any
recommendations tutorials books etc
think what did I see there are some
advanced react training courses I think
it's called there's a of course called
advanced react training so try to search
for that I believe they're like online
courses that you can do so I would yeah
definitely check that out
I'm sorry I lost my place
Moshi ko says how do you keep motivated
with programming I really like it so
it's not that hard to stay motivated and
I don't there's just like no let me see
it like there's there's no choice but to
not be motivated really like yeah I work
full-time I have a family I have bills
to pay like I do I do the work right and
I like the work so it's like even if I
start to get like where I'm not
motivated I still have to go in and do
the work every day and once I start to
program I I get into it I get motivated
so it's not hard for me I guess but like
what really motivates me like working
with new stuff you know working on like
cool projects like that that is kind of
motivating so you know learning new
things motivates me creepy says is it
necessary for a full stack developer to
learn other back-end languages than
JavaScript like PHP ergo it's not
necessary unless you're the job that you
want says it's necessary right so so
much of what you're gonna learn is going
to be dependent on what you have to
learn to do whatever you're getting paid
to do
w3 develops as should I learn JavaScript
PHP with Python simultaneously is my
first language I don't know why you
would want to learn PHP and Python
simultaneously
they're both back-end languages unless
there's a good reason I then I don't
know I don't know why you would need to
learn about you certainly could though
I mean JavaScript with one of those
other language just make sense if you
want to just do JavaScript front-end and
pair them with a Python or PHP back-end
there's no reason why you couldn't do it
it's just I don't understand that
particular combination
sooraj says nowadays which language is
used more for development for game and
webs what ok so javascript is where it's
at for web development no doubt for game
development that's a whole different
story I don't know that much about game
development so I'm gonna have to defer
if anybody else knows more about game
development then you know please let us
know but you can definitely make web
games with JavaScript but like serious
game development like the games that are
making millions of dollars like I to be
honest with you I have no idea what
programming languages or frameworks
they're using I hear like unity unity I
know is a tool I guess that a lot of
games use I don't know what the
underlying language those
laying any TV says can you share how
much you earn as a developer for a
Dick's I don't know I'm not exactly sure
what Dick's Sporting Goods what their
opinion is on sharing salary stuff so in
general I'm I think Chang salaries is a
good thing but seeing as how I just
started out there I don't want to do
anything that they would not like right
away so maybe at some point I will share
that but maybe just not right now like I
want to be a little bit more careful
about it right now so hopefully
hopefully you understand all right I
think I've gotten through all the
questions and that's good because I
definitely have to get to my job my
regular job now thank you all so much
for watching I had a lot of good
questions so I love that and I will be
back next week probably Wednesday
morning of next week I'm still hoping to
do something either like a live stream
or a video about graph QL on my channel
the link to my personal channels in the
description just haven't had time so
maybe this weekend will be the weekend
that I get to that so if you're
interested in that be looking out for
that otherwise yeah thanks again for
watching and for all your help
a big thank you to to Chris for the
amazing pool request and yeah so I'll
see you next week and have a great
weekend